[Music]
a lot of people are gonna say the worst
part about austin is that he never
streams i think it was the brown face
for five years raj
raj my indian brother
[Music]
you do you want to be great
hello
i'm happy to i'm happy to interview my
my brown brothers
he's white
he's white
yeah
and he's actually a white dude named
austin hello everybody thank you so much
for being here
since 2013 since i started on twitch i i
go i always been known as raj patel raj
on twitch i want to make a change and i
it feels better i want to be named after
me i don't want to be named after you
know something that that i don't really
have the right to borrow from
but it's not about me it's about my
guests what i have to do during my show
is i need to
make sure that they're getting the
attention and where the light is on them
my role as the host is to delegate that
conversation and guide it in a direction
and so which that their my guests are
you know elevated to the best version of
themselves on the show you madonna i
didn't think this was going to come hey
yeah
[Music]
people
i've been able to grow a lot and be more
out i came out as gay uh be more open
with my sexuality and just be open about
me and you know the austin show hosted
by austin show
[Music]
there are two types of streamers out
there those who welcome you into their
lives and those who do everything in
their power to keep you out the latter
often go to great lengths to protect
their identities whether it's because
they value their privacy or because they
want to keep their real lives offline
some try to erase all traces of their
faces from the internet a lot of people
think it's like a business thing or a
gimmick i just deeply [ __ ] hate my
face and people's expectations at this
point
are ridiculous and unachievable
some never reveal any personal details
about themselves i've gotten some advice
from other people and
some of them some streamers have said if
there's one thing i can go back and do i
wouldn't tell people where i lived
others create an entire experience for
their viewers by inventing a persona to
hide behind this is my nun skin
oh okay
all right that's nice i protect the lord
in 2013 the runescape community was
introduced to raj patel a streamer who
never showed his face spoke with a heavy
indian accent and spent his time playing
runescape as well as getting to know his
fellow streamers oh my goodness so nice
to see you it's nice
well i i was honestly i was just sitting
around browsing around
and i was actually browsing the music
channel because i'm looking for
somebody with beautiful singing voice
and i found you
my goodness gracious you are the best
best best but as it turned out raj
wasn't raj at all his real name was
austin otherwise known nowadays as
austin show and he was about to create a
monster my name's austin show and this
is jackass
but before austin's show became one of
the biggest streamers on twitch back in
his college days austin actually dreamt
about becoming a commercial airline
pilot i like started pursuing aviation
seriously and i always loved flying and
like i always loved i always kind of had
this weird obsession with like i loved
going through the airport and like going
through security i know it's like it's
like narcissistic but i like love going
to the airport and going through
security and like i would record
takeoffs like with my like one of those
cameras you know one of the handheld
cameras you know with the little screen
on them that's cool um
and i just love traveling and going
through the whole process and everything
you know unfortunately austin realized
his future salary wasn't exactly the
stuff dreams were made of but even so
his time pursuing his aerial ambitions
wasn't wasted between watching videos of
planes training on pro flight simulators
and looking for something to occupy him
in his downtime austin discovered
youtube and shortly after twitch back in
those days the platform was pretty much
exclusively devoted to gaming but austin
saw its potential to be something more a
sort of an extension of mainstream
entertainment like the reality tv shows
that captivated austin in his teen years
[Applause]
putting yourself out there though isn't
easy and austin felt like he needed
someone a character to really make his
stream stand out growing up in central
oregon austin had many friends who came
from an indian background and so austin
decided to take on the guise of raj
patel a charismatic confident [ __ ]
disturber that was a creation inspired
by austin's salad days you do you want
to be great
hello mmorpgs were all the rage on
twitch in the early 2010s and he chose
runescape a game austin had been playing
since 2005 as his entry point into the
streaming world stand before you today
my fellow eop brother as an indian not
with a red dot on my forehead no but
with a red cape on my back with you and
a fallout that we have waited for so
long for you see the mighty foliage
final orange elite is still deciding to
tread water in the territory of the
pirate i've been through some [ __ ] and
runescape like you know i was a at one
point i was a prostitute just nice
so much about you know what i'm talking
about
and as attached as austin was to
runescape raj couldn't be contained
within the confines of just one game the
more streamers austin encountered in his
digital travels the more apparent
twitch's potential for mayhem became
it's got to 10 mil
all right [ __ ] it you just put in just
do a goddamn steak nobody gives a [ __ ] i
just you start something stuff okay okay
now there have been those who tried to
make twitch and youtube reality tv a
thing and failed miserably
greetings travelers and welcome to the
hottest dating scene sweep in the nation
fireside and chill
where we host speed dates
that pair singles together in the most
romantic setting possible
hearthstone arena mode attempting to
make streaming into tv 2.0 didn't seem
like it was the right play so when
austin aka raj decided to give it a try
he wanted to do things differently what
set twitch celebrities apart from their
mainstream counterparts was the
willingness to truly be themselves for
their viewers whether it was their real
selves or the version of themselves they
presented online didn't really matter
what did matter though was that the true
force of the guest personalities as
their viewers knew them had a chance to
come out jon is a bit of a crazy guy
right i know he's a bit of a psychopath
i'm not psychopath maybe not sociopath
he's just really he's just
um it's unstable content yes which is a
little bit unstable would you be able to
handle that long term
yes
because i'm the same so i would
understand why all right i guess i'll
just drink the rest of this hot sauce on
my own
[Music]
i don't know if i can handle any more
loads
[Laughter]
and whether it was the rocheller and
rashloret the twitch version of the
bachelor in bachelorette the raj royale
a debate show king of the hill or the
raj talent show the tensions were high
and the takes were hot there's fat girls
fat people exist
that was really bob that was [ __ ]
offensive
seriously dude all right i take it back
fat people are a myth has to be taller
than six foot anything under nah man
hit the gym man if you're under six foot
hit the door you can't hit the gym and
grow heights oh my god you can't hit the
chest no you can't
grabbing somebody's breasts are two
different things right i mean it is too
difficult what's the difference i have
to make an analogy because you're too
stupid to understand the original
subject so that if i brought it to race
maybe it was something you could
understand a little bit easier if you
want me to use a different analogy i
could do that as well you want to pick a
topic or yeah we've got 10 body parts
googled it that we don't use fact organs
we've got 10 organs in our body we don't
actually use so work that one out
slicker
it's just dick do you say you're pretty
pretty dense what do you say
you're pretty fat
but as controversial as the shows could
get the biggest controversy was the host
himself hello everybody thank you so
much for being here press one in the
chat if you got your finger in your and
all that [ __ ] by early 2018 it was
painfully clear that as a man of irish
and lebanese descent austin would have
to do something about raj patel a man
named raj patel also streams
okay
yeah whatever you guys i'm happy to i'm
happy to interview my my brown brothers
he's white
he's white
yeah
is he like adopted
uh i think he just decided to name
himself raj patel
i
i think that's the lore austin was no
longer hiding his face so the jig was up
a long time ago
i've been the person
who has been playing raj
patel the guy that you know is raj patel
for like the past what four years it's
been the accent was the first thing to
go followed by dropping patel from raj
patel the name raj was the last
remaining vestige of the faux
personality austin once hid behind and
in june of 2020 he released a twitlonger
announcing that he was now going to go
by austin and remove raj from all of his
content offerings going forward in the
statement austin apologized profusely to
anyone who may have been hurt or
offended by his portrayal of the
southeast asian community and vowed to
do better in the future even if there's
like a minority group of people that are
like i feel in this case significant um
you know i want to make a change and i
it feels better i want to be named after
me i don't want to be named after you
know
something that that i don't really have
the right to borrow from the move took
place just a few months after austin
openly came out so he was clearly trying
to be as true to himself as possible
although at first a few people saw the
revelation as nothing more than clout
chasing okay i kept reading comments on
reddit and people were like well
you know
he's he was faking indian for many years
so i think he's just this is his new
fake plot
to fake it for views
and uh so i read a couple of those
comments and i thought okay it is the
minority most people know
but i do think
i do think it is important that i came
out so i did for the most part austin's
truth bombs landed well with his fans
and contributors and despite losing the
name recognition austin's shows never
lost their appeal and continued to do as
well as ever with celebrity appearances
like little nos x's adding an extra
layer of drama into the mix gap did you
did you have another question that you
wanted to ask beautiful no apparently
you know people get distracted when i
talk apparently no no no
if you have another question that's okay
do you have another question
yeah okay now whatever just flew by you
i don't know what it was why is it more
important than me
i'm right here trying to get your love
and you think there's an object flying
past you is more important than i don't
understand
make it make sense in march of 2021
austin joined hundred thieves as a
content creator a position coveted by
many a streamer but when it came down to
it austin didn't even need mainstream
celebrities or an org to succeed even if
the names of the shows changed austin's
tried and true streamer-centric formula
had turned all of his content into a
phenomenon that took on a life of its
own and drew thousands of viewers each
time austin's show went live the biggest
names on the internet flocked to
austin's maelstrom of personalities for
a dose of reality distilled down to its
most entertaining and hard-hitting parts
hassan
i have some potentially bad news for you
we have gotten in contact with one of
your ex-girlfriends and we've brought
them we decided that we'd bring them on
the show
live to confront you they're very upset
oh if you will
yeah it's will there's no way it's not
will this is okay one of your
ex-girlfriends is very very upset at you
yeah at first at first i was terrified i
was like what the [ __ ] and then it's
definitely well go ahead rocheller's
successor lover host pitted streamers
against one another in a bid to be the
one chosen by the episode's bell or bow
of the ball but that choice isn't even
the main point of the game the true
spectacle lies in the reveal at the very
end was the final contestant there for
love or did they just want to get hosted
by austin schled had a decision to make
before the show began and he chose
he chose love what
he chose love
[Music]
oh easy he
chose
[Music]
you've never been so cute before you're
giving me all of you i'm the best i'm
the best the rest of austin's content no
matter if it deals with dating or
something else entirely rarely fails to
get to the heart of the matter either in
a way i'm glad i didn't want i thought i
was gonna get disqualified like first or
second i even made a bet i'm gonna post
a picture of my butt cheek so i was
getting kind of nervous like oh my god
more often than not austin's shows offer
us a fascinating window into the human
psyche whether the insight has to do
with love politics or the limits of
individual talent a window we just have
to be willing to open just be accepting
accept people for who they are
and love people for who they are you
know
they're not always going to be like you
and if his numbers or anything to go by
austin just might have cracked the
twitch reality tv code love it or hate
it none of us can take our eyes off of a
masterfully executed
train wreck awesome it's nice seeing you
finally get some good content on
austin's newest show he was he had the
legendary robert paulson on and instead
of diving into some of the incredible
stories he probably has austin spent the
entire time flexing that the vikings
were better than the lions and comparing
the growth on your vocal cords to his
throat cancer
a true display of austin taking someone
else's story and making it about himself
if austin becomes any more self-obsessed
he'll have to change his name again but
this time this time to ms kif
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tech talk